was war das zum ersten bild eines
schwarzen loches gibt es noch eine menge
mehr zu erzählen und hier gibt es am
animationen die sich mit der entdeckung
beschäftigen bis gestern haben wir immer
nur spekuliert wie ein schwarzes loch
wohl aussehen würde und gestern haben
wir es zum ersten mal gesehen zwar noch
extrem und schafft aber die vorhersagen
trafen zu jetzt also mehr spektakuläre
bilder und animationen krieg substanzen
wirken hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nicht los geht's ja ich
willkommen wie konnte dieses bild nur
entstehen das ist wirklich eine
sensation denn dafür wurde die technik
der very large baseline interferometrie
genutzt auf deutsch interferometrie mit
sehr langen basis linien mit diesen
linien sind die abstände zwischen
verschiedenen radioteleskopen
gemeinschaft in den 50er jahren wurde
die technik unter der beteiligung von
roger johnson entwickelt er entwickelte
eine technik mit der die aufnahmen der
teleskope über atomuhren synchronisiert
werden und dabei entstehen tatsächlich
virtuelle teleskope die fast so groß wie
unsere erde sind das liegt an
verschiedenen phänomen zum einen drehen
sich alle teleskope mit der erddrehung
das heißt dass sie jeweils aus einer
anderen perspektive auf das objekt
schauen dadurch decken sie einen
erheblichen teil der erdkugel ab und das
bild das dabei entsteht oder die immer
größere datenmenge ermöglicht ein immer
schärferes bild zum anderen blicken die
teleskope zu jedem zeitpunkt aus einem
anderen winkel auf das objekt das heißt
dass durch die verschiedenen
perspektiven auch eine riesige anzahl an
störungen herausgerechnet werden können
und zum anderen haben sie auch
untereinander verschiedene winkel gäbe
ist diese technik nicht wäre ein so
scharfes bild vom rc 87 bei weitem nicht
möglich gewesen das weltraumteleskop
hubble hat uns bisher die
beeindruckendste aufnahme des riesigen
schwarzen lochs geliefert auf ihm war
ein jet aus dem schwarzen loch zu sehen
der fast in unsere richtung zeigt jets
entstehen ja aus dem material der
akkretionsscheibe und werden durch
verschiedene effekte rund um das loch
senkrecht für drehachse christoph
tausende lichtjahre ins
geschossen und diese akkretionsscheibe
das ist ja die scheibe die sich in
diesem fall mit 3,6 millionen kilometern
pro stunde um das schwarze loch dreht in
der sich materie durch die hohe
geschwindigkeit aufheizt bevor sie im
loch verschwindet damit war klar dass
wir wenn wir auf das schwarze loch
gucken von oben aussehen denn die
akkretionsscheibe dreht sich von uns aus
gesehen um das schwarze loch herum es
ist so als würden wir den saturn von
oben sehen und die ringe drumherum
da hätten wir eine andere perspektive
würde das schwarze loch diese
akkretionsscheibe unter das licht von
ihr so trocken dass es aus den
verschiedenen perspektiven schon
ziemlich seltsam aussehen würde
unglaublich was das schwarze loch hier
mit der akkretionsscheibe macht und ihr
wird auch deutlich was wir sehen nämlich
nicht das schwarze loch selbst sondern
seinen schatten der ereignishorizont ist
nämlich bei diesem 6,5 milliarden
sonnenmassen schweren supermassiven
schwarzen loch 100 milliarden kilometer
groß zehnmal so groß wie unser
sonnensystem
der schatten dem er in der mitte sehen
der ist aber nur noch 40 milliarden
kilometer grund also etwa viermal so
groß wie unser sonnensystem gesehen
damit hier direkt die relativistischen
auswirkungen eines schwarzen loches das
zeit und raum in atemberaubender weise
kommt materie die sich dem
ereignishorizont nähert wird aus unserer
sicht immer langsamer solche effekte
kennen wir hier auf der erde zum
beispiel von millionen die fast mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit auf die erde zu
reisen deshalb wirkt die zeit die nation
auf sie durch diesen relativistischen
effekt erreichen sie trotz ihrer kurzen
über lebensdauer von nur 2,2
mikrosekunden die erdoberfläche und
pyramiden können zum beispiel
durchleuchtet werden
aus unserer sicht haben sie rund zehn
mal mehr zeit bis sie zerfallen
das ist schon verrückt und um das
schwarze loch ist alles noch mal
deutlich verrückter was wir am wort der
akkretionsscheibe der ganz gut sehen und
auch die helligkeitsunterschiede in der
akkretionsscheibe sind mit einem solchen
effekt zu erklären da wo sie sich in
unsere richtung dreht ist sie heller wo
sie sich wegdreht dunkler auf der seite
nämlich wo sich die aggression scheibe
in unsere richtung dreht schießt sie ja
auf uns zu also auch die licht photonen
und deshalb schießt sie deutlich mehr
photonen in unsere richtung
hier einfach eben pro zeiteinheit mehr
photonen zu uns geschossen werden in der
anderen richtung wenn sie sich von uns
weg dreht werden weniger photonen zu uns
geschossen
das entfernt sich ja das liegt die
lichtquelle das ist schon alles ziemlich
verrückt und wir werden sicher noch viel
viel mehr zu dieser entdeckung in den
nächsten wochen und monaten erfahren
sehr intensiv hat sich auch blogger
watson mit dem thema beschäftigt und
beschreibt noch mal sehr sehr gut wie
die technik hinter dem bild aussieht
schaut also unbedingt beim vorbei wie
fotografiert man ein schwarzes loch
draufklicken anschauen und doktor watson
unbedingt abonnieren es lohnt sich bis
dann bleibt dran